that flavor world joey cogo Diaz and
Pasadena check it out and [ __ ] that's
how we do it math flavor one drop of the
[ __ ] brownie your cannabis brownie
keep it what what mad flavor world is
how we do it Dancing with the brothers
[Applause]
[Music]
Pasadena [ __ ] this how we do it it's
your birthday what what what that's how
we do it [ __ ] mad flavor world
whatever we get to that's where the
party's at [ __ ] what mad flavor
we'll check it out in the back
that's how we live [ __ ] in California
get it together
[Music]
[Music]
keep writing keep riding that dick what
what what for months I've been telling
you people about a secret I found I
could not [ __ ] believe I grew up on
the East Coast I grew up on Dunkin
Donuts that was God to me [ __ ]
growing up well if these cause I had a
few donuts but it wasn't the same I'm
saying when I was a kid daddy anthemic
donut with the chocolate the white
powder on top and I dropped the ball you
leave them in the trunk will go over
your [ __ ] shirt there's goddamn plans
got no respect for nobody trying to make
a video here [ __ ]
so anyway
I come on the couch
before the pounds will hurt Oleg I have
[ __ ] steaks milkshakes you don't say
the real deal but then I move to North
Hollywood and I discover the [ __ ]
place
[ __ ] Dunkin Donuts this place rips it
apart you understand me because the
people were born Dunkin Donuts now it's
an investment they never went to Dunkin
Donuts is a kid you don't know what the
[ __ ] that dollar suppose this tastes
like
not to mention all these places took the
trans fat out
you don't say they took the fat out of
[ __ ] donut then what the [ __ ] am i
don'tuh for but all jokes aside my spot
right here you understand me
yum yum [ __ ] donuts you follow
me by Mexicans they hit twenty four
[ __ ] hours they got delicious
doughnuts let's take a look inside here
see what you got did you get me one
honey look at that how beautiful oh
that's beautiful
jelly we're gonna chocolate chocolate
and it will be punctual honey
see
what'd you get - look how beautiful just
one that's all I want right there that's
you smoke 50 numbers when you come in
here forget about it look at this roll
here
you got your notes you got your water if
you [ __ ] move the Swedes are gonna
water you Papillon all right
[Applause]
that's a young young daughter pissy
Pokemon not bad
about fifth point who they do like the
yogurt today I walked around and [ __ ]
90 degree weather I deserve to stay
black only show you one of the best cat
in the world is my man Timmy Timmy likes
to take showers every day
well he showers he comes in relation to
the brush him and brush his face he's my
sign meat I named the Matt but a little
creases to hold up one of the Exorcist
be me why do you do this to me and this
is his whole world he loves this stuff
you know like this you get my nice back
right baby look at that you can live to
be a hundred and you don't have a cat
that takes a shower like that this is
how I wrote about my gum dr. Amy I'm
over here and acupuncture see her a
couple diggin was there my stomach got
one of my chest got one in my leg just
trying to get everything in all the doc
baby says no more banana bread so I'm
gonna go banana bread regimen just
smoking weed to go to yoga and taking a
camp myself right that things what are
you laughing about back names those
needles and stuff like that
why can't even know what THC that's it
so I don't want to eat it no more
anybody debris that's it's like a
vicodin prescription to having a whole
loaf of banana bread mad flavors well
showing it how we keep in shape here
trying to live for you guys peace out
that's not the Amy fleet machine playing
guys stay black well I'm here one of my
favorite books in the block come here
Millie is my Milli Vanilli
oh my god video is my girl milli vanilli
that's the Greek good morning that's my
other girl right there
this is milli vanilli see it's not about
cats I got a couple dogs in the
neighborhood I'll SiC on you to Joey
COGO Diaz mad flavor world mad flavor
will stay black bye bye Milli Vanilli
isn't my girl right here have a good day
stay black my flavor was not just about
cats anymore
[Music]